[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
your waking world is shaped
by dreams
dreams
and nightmares that i create
and which i must control
he's out there looking for me
his name
can you imagine the damage he could do
i need your help
if dreams disappear then so will
humanity i could do without dreams for a
while i haven't had a decent night's
sleep in ages
i'm not gonna stop
until i've reshaped this world
tell us
what power of dreams
[Applause]
i thought about giving up
but i have a job to do when i do it
things have changed
your eyes will tell me everything
every thought every feeling
[Music]
my creations do not walk amongst the
living killing mortals for pleasure
oh you don't think dreams can die
let's find out
nightmares do not belong in the waking
world
oh turns out i fit right in
dreams don't die
mr sandman
bring me a dream
[Music]
[Music]
i am
[Applause]
[Music]
i am
i am
[Music]
i'm not sure if i meant to kill it
[Music]
bad idea
we do what we think is right
even if it hurts the ones we love
people thought i was nuts
[Music]
no one believed this could happen
no one ever thinks bad things will
happen
it's the media it's hype
the cdc is freaking next door if
anything was really wrong they'd be all
over it
i am studying the homo mortis
everything from their behavior
psychology to migration patterns
what psychology they don't do anything
other than walk around and try to kill
us their study done
starting to think if you're gonna choose
yourself over others you should make
sure that your life is worth saving
i'm still kicking and most everyone else
isn't happy story mr sunshine
you just hold up with your protein
powder
we're not
what sort of terrible thing would
frighten a little girl so much that she
hides from her own mother
we decide who we are
you
you can decide
wow jesus what the hell man killer
control no overwhelming feelings of rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to gen 4 when you sleep was the air
horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
yeah who's your best friend
nikki
spandex spandex is your best friend
being a hulk asks for balance
[Music]
you have so much more to learn
yes
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
if you want to go back to your life as a
lawyer i i respect that
he doesn't mean that
more and more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for
them and i want the she-hulk to be the
face of
jennifer wolves
namaste i have a serious conflict of
interest this man tried to kill my
cousin bruce yeah that's quite all right
oh
[Music]
people only care because i'm
representing emil bonski i think they
care cause they're like hey that girl's
green
do your thing god i really like this
outfit
i'm not proud of this
as walters we answer to a higher power
our universe is on the edge of a
precipice
i am a lawyer
we do things by the book
the book of the shanty no the book of
american
uh loss
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero
let's do this
you know that friend you had in high
school
who was way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
[Music]
hello
i think i'm jealous is that what i'm
feeling
[Music]
greetings bill nye here
welcome to the disaster institute earth
is constantly on the edge of disaster
viewer discretion is advised
why is it that every disaster movie
begins with someone in power ignoring a
scientist people are sick of all the
doom and gloom because it happens more
than you might think
this is gonna really start
okay
it doesn't have to go down that way
together we can save earth
with science
join me as i take on six world-ending
disasters
each one
leading to my imminent doom brace
yourself
so yeah i guess you could say i really
am dying to save the world
starfleet get your star fleet prepare
yourself for warp 10 excitement discover
the undiscovered country
the uss cerritos remains impounded while
their captain stands trial have you lost
your mind captain carol freeman stands
again i can't believe this i wonder how
mariner's taking it oh i'm taking it
taking it to the limit did you time your
entrance to say that what no oh yeah she
did
starfleet isn't all about being fed
fruit by erotic aliens with slightly
different nose ridges i could get really
used to this kind of treatment
sometimes you gotta get your hands dirty
it's
on this is an unauthorized launch
so begins the greatest adventure of your
lives
these broken rocks are reading our
nightmares but i don't like my
nightmares
so magical there's gonna be times when
you need to make a mess of things
before you can fix them
like how i'm gonna have to cut this
guy's foot off so we can grow him a new
one wait what was that
whatever happens
we're gonna be right beside you we're in
this together
[Music]
[Music]
i can't believe we're at deep space nine
wait wait just buy me some time uh sir
how do we do that uh i don't know just
circle around and pretend we're in awe
of the pylons
[Music]
um just keep circling
[Music]
i have spent my life trying to protect
my family
our battle begins today
[Music]
do you remember what it felt like
to live in peace
the world has changed
this new weapon more powerful than you
can imagine
it'll kill thousands
no fight just death
my queen the travantians now can destroy
entire cities
will be ours
we now have the greatest weapon this
world has ever known no religion
will stop it war is quite an elegant
solution
i am your queen
my sister hunted us for 17 years and she
won't stop now
i never had to fight for my crown
now that crown will be forged in the
burning flames of war
i will be a queen reborn
you know in your heart what needs to be
done
hit them again
this moment
if he's a molecule
[Music]
we thought the war
at last
was ended
today
our days of peace
begin
we thought our joys would be unending
we thought our light
would never dim
the skies
are strange
[Music]
the moment we feared
[Music]
evil does not sleep
it wins
beyond the darkness tempting shadow
to barriers all beneath the mountain
he has no one name but many
if the evil rising is left unchecked
it will take us off
find the light and the shadow will not
find you
together we can survive this
fight with me
each of us must decide who we shall be
there can be no trust between hammer and
rock
eventually one or the other
must surely break
you have been told many lies
you must prepare lissa for a new role as
head of the dragomir family and rose
she'll do her duty
is this something that you want there
are a parade of people dying to be on
the throne
the only thing separating this dominion
from that fate is me
[Music]
then go out there and show them all what
you've got and if i've got nothing then
i will get you out i promise you that
guardians are raised to be tough
no matter how good you are there's good
enough and there's gone
i want to protect my best friend from
danger
good
you staying out of trouble oh you know
me i'm always dancing alongside of it
there's
something strange happening
we will survive because there is no
other option
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for coming
i hoped you would
i have a lot to say
we need to find horsebeat before it gets
to anybody
you're running out of time
[Music]
you want to die quick
you want to die screaming
no but this isn't going to be easy is it
ever
you go after the mountains i'll crush
you no matter how bleak things look
this is not the end
none of us are safe as long as she's
still breathing
you know who i am
this world is broken
this isn't the future my mom and dad
fought for i wish things were how you
want them to be
i have to keep you safe
the hell is going to rain down on you
[Applause]
people remember the last thing you do
[Music]
end of each story
is very important
[Music]
how do you want yourself
[Music]
heard stories
walkers that can climb walls and open
doors
i was never sure if they were just
stories
he's in my head
[Music]
the year was 1910
new orleans
[Music]
you could say i managed and operated
diversified portfolio of enterprises
i was being hunted
and i was completely unaware was
happening
i've been watching you for some time now
louie
[Music]
i can swap this life of shame
swap it out for a dark gift
you just have to ask me for it
[Applause]
[Music]
me [ __ ] five sin
i lay down with the devil
and i can't think nothing anymore
lord help me i am weak i wanna die
[Music]
you don't fear me louie
you feel yourself
[Applause]
i ask the questions you answer the
questions anything that can't be
verified i send to my researcher
so
how long have you been dead
what ever happened to chucky
[Music]
gee where the hell are you you're the
only one i can talk to about what really
happened
it's been a really tough year
are you
as happy as you made me
who is this
and why the hell are you calling to make
sure you're home
this cross mr evans and mr wheeler
do you know why you're here
i know your history
it's just a doll
when do we get to start stabbing people
no matter what he's going to come for us
again
i hate that doll
you need tiffany
to get what's
[Music]
this is for kyle
hi
i'm chucky
wanna pray
just looking at me is scary enough to
give you a heart attack
oh my god thank you
dear god
and or grown up baby jesus
i may not exactly know
how it all works
like what life is handed out to who and
why
but the mistake was made pretty
obviously not in my favor
welcome to slushy shack how may i help
you
you don't have to say that every time
you know actually i do it's in the
manual there is no manual
hi sarah hey original
why would she waste her time on a loser
like you
i was promised so much that i did not
receive
whatever down payment was made before i
was born
no i want a refund
reggie
have we met before
i believe everyone deserves a refund
do you want to be ours
reginald
you smell amazing
[Applause]
the weirdest dream last night no you're
not dreaming
you're a vampire
nothing changes
until you feed
we can't just let anyone join our ranks
monsters like you
don't belong here whoa do i need a
lawyer let you know the andres will not
survive the night
i want to drink your blood excuse me
i own the night i'll pay you 25
25 for my blood 50 but we have to go to
atm first
now
what's up
[Music]
have you ever spent any time in the
metaverse
that's way above my pay-grade pal
i'm just the janitor
i got an nft for you nothing
i ain't elizabeth
there have been reports of repeated
harassment from home it's anonymous
david that's her that tracks yeah that
tracks carol can you tell poppy to stop
acting like a cat i'm not acting like a
cat addict
you see carol these kind of meetings did
not happen when i worked here we had
this exact meeting carol if i may you
may not
[Music]
it's an honor mr grim
i'm a huge fan i like this guy please
kill me
really
you're only as good as those around you
[Music]
those days on the enterprise
made me a better man a better father
better friend
i thought i could inspire people bring
justice to an unjust universe
you have no idea how hard it is to be in
this world
you're not presumed to know what i have
and have not sacrificed for this
[Music]
we have to be willing to go through that
door to what's next
there's a whole universe out there
wherever you go we go
here in this moment let's do what we
spent our lives learning to be great at
as long as you and your crew
remain steadfast
you are never without hope
[Music]
you